[Music]
and it actually works news Wow
submit it by [ __ ] the haters mad man but
keep stay here so we have somebody pick
on there yeah and please like hit the
like button please subscribe a 22 year
old scammed Amazon out of three hundred
seventy thousand dollars of return
shipments of dirt right yeah dude smart
this guy's a smart guy yeah but like all
thousand wait you need to I may have to
reread it again so this guy in Spain
scammed Amazon out of 370 grant and his
methodology is pretty simple he would
order an item yeah like usually like
pretty expensive and then he would
replace that item with that same weight
in dirt what did people find out no no
he's gonna do this forever what's up
yeah how did he get come he messed up
cuz you didn't bail the country fast
enough like if you got your 300 G's and
you left wait so he did it all at once
no we got greedy and kept doing it he
didn't change a scam exactly what did he
buy hope you got some good all kind of
[ __ ] electronics mostly boxes of dirt
and just he basically took advantage of
an Amazon sales policy which is that
they they will allow you to return any
item as long as you send them the box
back yeah so he's like okay and they had
such a long process Isis yeah so there
was a huge queue so yeah so they he know
this he knew that there was a queue for
it oh yeah he kind of figured it out as
he went and so so they found a bunch of
boxes in Barcelona of dirt and they're
like and then the cops started to put
together where these were coming from
like where is it let me look at the
address
oh he's right here let's go oh this be a
movie on this where it's like the wolf
of Amazon you just see him start
climbing the ranks we're turning all
these things and has this dirt Empire
and just see it all because it matter
where to get the dirt from good point
yes
they never I never saw straight-up coke
lab but with ladies putting dirt inside
the [ __ ] box it ladies in their
underwear
don't you see only [ __ ] dirt from me
he went pot dirt if he just like got
dirt from his backyard the question it
would be would use all the dirt from his
backyard it would go down to the pipes
and his mom's like what the [ __ ] so he'd
start to buy dirt to buy dirt and chicks
is trying to smuggle dirt out in their
bras yeah he's like no put it back
dirt shortage so yeah it was doing so
well that he ended up founding a company
called guar Tech which basically means
technology yeah yeah he was like this is
like we started a company what kind of
company is a thousand dollars scam shell
company do we know oh it was a shell
company for his dirty column Joe Dirt no
he has a name is Jose dirt yeah this was
his name is just says 22 year old man
James Kiehl Bert quarte hang James
Gilbert corpus yeah
that doesn't sound very Spanish yeah no
but that's why I called a quartet
because it's his last name good good way
to protect him Susie yeah what yeah
here's some really large breadcrumbs
here's my address in my last name
so unfortunately his parents are also
being charged with viable what do they
do Hamdi dragon I think he was doing
that other place oh that's that do they
know go to the house with no dirt in the
front lawn this worries me about like
being a parent it's like like I love
Isaac Isaac is a great kid by all means
but man like if you were to take the
wrong turn or whatever I'm like I'm not
going down for you [ __ ] like you
keep me out of your [ __ ] man tell them
this now it's like drinking a juice box
Murli you know you can't you can't look
he's got his Capri Sun
[ __ ] if you ever gonna tell I'm
not bailing you out there we say Asian
cultures are shame culture that's right
because our parents are always like if
you [ __ ] up this is on me do not shame
us shame your family I'm about to change
shame me change the stereotype for you
because I'm already fun I'm already
coming up with a bill fund for my future
kids that it's gonna be a [ __ ] what
do you call it like like a safe house
with a ghetto
we package and all that [ __ ] if they
[ __ ] commit a crime I won't be like
all right I knew this will come in handy
here's your [ __ ] gun here's a new set
of clothes and ID here we go I got an
apartment in Costa Rica and you're here
you're out you're already pre
determining vandalism or something
stupid you know it's not even a hard
crew but then Joe's dumb [ __ ] kid
gets caught with a duffel bag and a gold
bag and all this [ __ ] and then Joe goes
down free no problem I got it for my dad
who gave you this fake passport my dad
yeah
well that's why I'll have a tracking
device and if cops get close I'll have
to hit that button where they go to
automatic eject what do you mean the
kids minded Jack's from his body
explosive he's gonna murder who's in
your hypothetical son is already dead
it's more daughter let's let's be
general new trick Nick yeah daughter or
son [ __ ] you destroy the evidence
I love both so this video can never come
out because if this actually happens
you've predetermined it you've
redeterminations murder so in a larger
case a u.s. a United States couple
pleaded guilty in 2017 to charges of
mail fraud and money laundering
after conning the same ecommerce giant
out of 1.2 million worth of of consumer
electronics so what this tells me is
Amazon is actually a good target cuz
look at how much money I mean just got a
you just gotta time it right because you
eventually get caught when you don't do
it you know any big enough business yeah
whatever what anybody got the biggest is
its zenith throws all kinds of front
happening but that's 1.2 million right
and in 300,000 those are those are good
enough getaway numbers yeah and these
people they basically set up a bunch of
false online identities and Amazon
accounts and then they bought like three
thousand different electronics like
tablets gaming consoles all that kind of
[ __ ]
and then they would use their amazon's
replacement policy so so it's like hey
we got this damaged and then they would
return it but it would be abandoned like
they would they would say that they
wanted to return it so they would get
the funds back and then
would not use that profile again so it's
fake
that is how they make money the garrison
you buy it you return it yeah and then
you have that you have the electric cell
that they know so in you reso oh
anywhere oh you know how they could make
more money is if they use stolen credit
cards see dude that's like you've been
in a grocery store and someone's a hey
when bust area yeah you being targeted
why you know I used to live in Koreatown
happened there didn't happen there see
you said all from the Koreans the
Mexican I move into I moved to do do
city years ago and that's when it
happened makes it I would have pictured
in Studio City all the Russian mob yeah
okay
goes in Koreatown and there are Koreans
yeah I know yeah because when I think of
stolen speakers I think Latino crime
when I think of stolen TV that I think
maybe Asian
maybe Russian mob if it's new you know
see I think methods
oh that too yeah yeah it really depends
if the jobs clean or not if it's about
yeah that's true automatic sits like
multiple boxes and there it I mean and
in there in the back of a truck I'm
thinking inside job it could be any
culture but if it's got like spaghetti
stain or something on it white trash
well if somebody's like you want to buy
some copper they would rear they rip off
copper like in in exposed wires and all
like rats it's copper valuable or some
[ __ ] yeah I don't know [ __ ] then yeah I
don't know anything about this yeah we
put on copper
tweakers been tweakers been using copper
for years like don't they do they
wouldn't he scrap electronics they pull
out and then they get the copper to get
that like meadows and they get you happy
they had to replace there was a lot of
electronics technology that was like
publicly exposed and they had to replace
a lot of that with different materials
because there
ripped off from copper so much this
tweakers didn't get gold from my
computer parts there's people that
[ __ ] mmm-hmm they pick at the little
gold I wonder what it's like to be a
human being that just like looks at
trash all day and goes I'm gonna be rich
like that I'm gonna talk about the poor
people like that sucks right I'm talking
about like there's middle-class people
that are like super frugal to the point
where they do some like weird [ __ ] dude
my mom Regan's that's like the
five-year-old that's staring underneath
the table look we're all freaking out
here dude that's like my mom's my mom's
a hoarder and so everything around her
she's like this isn't good with millions
and you're just like ha Jesus like some
old black & decker toaster that's still
in the box that she's like that's new
and you're like dude it was new in 1985
she doesn't care that's like that's
living in a dream
yeah cuz everything is expensive do you
walk in you're like oh my god this is
like Beverly Hills dude that's like
people with really dirty pools and
they're like I got nice pool and then
you go over their place like well
backyard this is gross inside yeah it's
like algae and the [ __ ] duck is on it
don't even say you got a pool that's a
pond what the [ __ ] definitely went to
friends house that was like that and I
was like oh I guess I guess we're
getting in and what happened afterwards
I mean it was cool nobody's I got a guy
there's no funny video features or
anything nah it was your skin itchy
after I know this chill but like I
definitely looked at I was like I mean
he does have a pool you wasn't mine it
was hot it is the pool yeah blind for 30
seconds that's like say my friend maybe
this with this food had eyes in it and
had a beat get it had feathers in it and
then you're like
[Laughter]
Wow that about Indian food because any
if it's never it never looks good so
it's just it looks like yeah right it
just always look no but it never it
visually like cuz it looks like mush you
want everything looks like much it's
just like a different color mush and I'm
like [ __ ] just eat it and
they're like [ __ ] breathe see I
wouldn't lie to you
best if you just got braces maybe of
food makes me feel like I'm about to do
some coloring or like some kind of
painting or something
on you and that stains you forever
forever and you were like I just got a
manicure I can't cook or eat Indian food
cuz tumeric getting their nails and it's
late stage do you like it spicy oh yeah
I don't for me I never and never
understand Indian people who don't eat
spicy Indian food really when you go to
like I get it those they exist but to me
it's just a little sad yeah when you go
to an Indian restaurant then do the
workers never asked you how spice don't
ever ask because like they always ask me
are you sure you want to show it my
roommate he's white and he eats spicy
food legitimate me too my spicy food
the red one if we go to an Indian
restaurant or like even a Thai
restaurant they'll never ask me and I'll
they'll go okay so how do you want it
and he'll be like spicy and the waiter
will always live to me it'll be like no
be like he wants it they feel bad like
telling him no and they'll look at me
just for you know clearance you don't
understand that's the conspire yes yeah
but they forget about Cajuns bro
everyone forgets about the cage but it's
not even on the same level oh dude it's
not on the same level no no no because
here's the difference between Cajun food
what I think is a seasoning seasoning an
Asian food is like built into the food
from step one we're in Cajun food it is
but there's a lot of hot sauce added a
lot of like a condiments after the
cooking you know why why cuz I've had
the hottest Indian food on earth and it
still needs [ __ ] hot sauce
he's one of the marijuana he's on watch
dude when I go there I have to sign a
[ __ ] waiver [ __ ] well I actually had
the hottest curry in the world which
they say in New York at Brick Lane it
was on man vs. food was it really and it
was pretty spicy me and my buddy did it
but wasn't a hide to [ __ ] my pants
immediately in the middle of night we
were both getting out and the best part
is they just take your picture they give
you gift certificate and a beer and I
was like this wasn't worth it [ __ ] this
dad it's not even free food
no oh they'll give you finish it you do
get over free
[Music]